Kirk Herbstreit ESPN college football
analyst and he joins us on behalf of
Coors Light and herby welcome good to
have you this morning how are you
dan how you doing I'm good I would like
to know how this is all playing out with
Wisconsin because it feels like all of a
sudden Wisconsin is the story of college
how did Wisconsin become the story of
college football here recently the
crosshairs here because of that that
undefeated record and fact that there
last week there were six unbeatens or
six football teams ahead of them and now
people are it's almost like the the only
potential Armageddon is if Wisconsin
runs the table wins the Big Ten
championship and they're 13 and oh
there's no way that they could be left
out and the reality is is if Alabama or
Georgia went out they potentially could
meet in Atlanta one of them wins out and
Notre Dame ends up winning out and
they're sitting there at 11 and 1 and
Clemson wins out and there's a very good
chance that they could went out and then
you have Oklahoma to Miami right now if
one of them were to win out then I think
that that's what won't give Wisconsin
isn't concerned because here we are
undefeated were 13 and oh and how can
you have all these one-loss teams ahead
of us self that's our Armageddon right
now but it feels like we want to get so
far get on the road with this because we
want this total we want this to blow up
in the committee's face to say say we
told you somebody got screwed here and
you know how this works every single
week who thought Ohio State was going to
get torched in Iowa right right right
that's college football you're so right
it happens every year we get to November
first two weeks of the rankings come out
next week the third week and people pull
their hair out because it's subjective
the difference between the NFL and MLB
and the NBA and college football and
even college coupe is its objective
analysis it's 13 people behind the
curtain nobody understands what they're
looking at so when you have clowns like
me
do everything we can to understand what
the 13 people are looking at it and what
they're trying to go through and we go
out here and we say well based on the
last three years and based on the office
and discussions we have with the
committee this is a minister in play and
then you know they come at us because
we're talking about hypotheticals but
what you just said is exactly on point
my thought is it was consonant up
winning out there's gonna be so much
carnage ahead of them that they're gonna
be just fine you know they're gonna end
up making it into the top four but
sitting here right now with all these
things ahead of them and everybody's all
uptight about they even thought about an
undefeated Wisconsin not making it
when did out a conference scheduling all
of a sudden become even more important
is it just this year's gin no no when we
went from the BCS with the computers and
all of that and the polls combined to
the playoff when we went to four teams
one of the things that the conference
commissioners came out and said that
they've told the committee that we want
to reward teams are willing to go out
and play tough games in September so if
a team like Oklahoma is willing to go to
Columbus in play Ohio State and risk a
potential loss while somebody else is
playing bethune-cookman you know whoever
else Southeast Indiana they're taking
the easy road and here's a team that's
playing a team like Ohio State or Ohio
State last year playing Oklahoma let's
reward those teams and if we get to the
end of the year and we're in doubt
here's a team that didn't play anybody
and their non-conference and here's a
team that played a top five or top ten
team we're gonna give them the benefit
of the doubt and let them that'll be a
tiebreaker that we'll use so basically
the conference commissioners told the
athletic directors and head coaches it
will it'll it'll benefit you to be
willing to go out there and and play
tougher games and in the non-conference
give me a team outside the top ten who
could eventually end up in the Final
Four
um I guess a long shot would be Michigan
State sitting there at 12:00 what a
story they are this year Mark Dantonio
serious consideration for national coach
of the year team was three and nine last
year they're seven and two they turned
the ball over a lot against Notre Dame
and lost early in the year
they're probably kicking themselves
losing the northwestern but they're
they're in a position to get to the Big
Ten championship this weekend they go to
Columbus to play Ohio State Buckeyes got
bombed by Iowa so what kind of Ohio
State team will they be playing the
winner really is in the driver's seat to
be able to get to the Big Ten
championship so Michigan State would be
the team kind of on the outside I would
say a better way to look at it would be
9 and 10 as teams that maybe could
navigate their way up if there are a
bunch of losses Washington you know poor
Washington it's like the Pacific
Northwest they lose the walk Arizona
State it's like they pencil their seams
and nobody pays attention to them
they're a really good team they deserve
to move up if they keep winning and all
burned an Auburn 7 and 2 they got
Georgia who's number one this week
they got Alabama who's number two well
and three weeks and so they played at
number one in the number two team if
they win both of those games you know
they might be able to kind of work their
way up as well what about USC
I think because of the way they lost a
Notre Dame on the road in South Bend
they would need a lot of help since like
Ohio State it's one thing to lose to
Iowa which teams do in November but to
lose 55 to 24 kind of sets you back they
lost to Notre Dame 49 USC lost inerting
49 to 14 the whole issue is fans Arnold
having almost unrealistic expectations
to deliver
I think that's weighed on him a little
bit this year and it's affected them
with that being said they've really
turned things around since that Boston
game they'd blown out Arizona State took
care of Arizona
they're gonna win the rest of their next
two games of Colorado UCLA they're
heading to the pac-12 championship
against Washington don't
now Washington and a lot of stuff would
have to happen for them to get up in
there as the pac-12 champ the leading
candidate right down for the Heisman is
it's gotta be Baker Mayfield for most of
the year it looks like say Quon Berkeley
because he was doing some things you
just don't see happen from a running
back he was returning kickoffs he was
jumping over people he was shaking
people in the open field and just having
those moments for the first probably
seven or eight weeks lost Ohio State and
they lost to Michigan State and why he's
gone through two straight losses Baker
Mayfield his stop just keeps going up
higher and higher and higher and you
know what was strange though Harvey is I
was looking I said to the dentists this
is before they played USC I said I have
my one of my favorite Heisman candidates
and I said he's not even in the top 50
odds wise to win the Heisman and I said
Khalil Tate and what he's done and you
know Arizona and then all of a sudden
the mothership comes out with their
recent Heisman rankings and he's fourth
on the list what happened yeah well did
you get on them because he went from not
playing and then he went on a four week
scratch you must have caught him early
on one of his mid October is when I saw
him and then I went this guy's
fascinating I don't know how good they
are but I know that he's fascinating to
do this and he didn't start this season
and then all of a sudden I said you know
give me the Heisman list to McLovin
he's not on the list I said how can this
guy I think he was leading the nation in
rushing how can he not be at least in
the top 50 with that and now all of a
sudden he's in the top five so and he
had a good show against USC so it's a
nice story it it really is a good story
it's a good I by you because their first
I want to say four games he wasn't
playing their starter Brandon Dawkins
went down he steps in against Colorado
and goes ballistic
in every game since then UCLA Cal
Washington State he's running for over
200 yards
Pat white when he was with Rick rod in
West Virginia them the way he was
running their offense
so the loss to us see he still put good
numbers up but you know how it is when
you lose a game it tends to affect the
hype and for whatever reason it's always
the Heisman Trophy even though it should
go to the best individual player I think
it's always about the maybe the most
valuable player and one of the best
teams that's what it's really become but
yeah without a doubt that kid exploded
onto the scene in October but right now
it's it's Baker Mayfield in the kid at
Notre Dame
Josh Addison talk about a big stage this
weekend if he goes crazy against Miami
on that stage his name will really start
to go come up running out of time I want
you to get your plug in you're joining
us on behalf of Coors Light yeah of
course like a an organization I've been
a part of now for for a few years they
came out with a new app back in August
it's it's a new rewards app called the
Coors Light XP and if you go to the App
Store all you have to do is search Coors
Light or Coors Light XP and if you use
my special code Curt football you can
use that today all the way up to the end
of Friday they'll allow you to earn 100
extra points on base so go download the
app and get involved in a lot of
different games for things you can win
by getting involved with yeah thank you
Herbie it's great to talk to you and
tell the boys we settle oh sure will Dan
take care man have a great week and
that's Kirk Herbstreit ESPN college
football analyst for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
[Music]